se conoce por ejemplo que estas cajas
primero estaban en la casa de Virginia
del expresidente después llegaron a la
casa en Indiana y
Greg Jacob que es representante del ex
vicepresidente dice que
estos cajas llegaron allá de forma
inadvertida las cajas además seguían
selladas con cinta de la casa blanca y
que cuando se encontraron fueron
directamente enviadas a una caja fuerte
para después ser entregadas a las
autoridades las autoridades precisamente
ya tienen pues acceso y control de esta
información confidencial archivos
nacionales ya recibió esta información
el departamento de Justicia también sabe
de esta información lo que no se conoce
Son detalles sobre Qué exactamente
decían estos documentos y qué grado de
confidencialidad tenían consecuencias
claras para el vicepresidente de cara
obviamente a su carrera para la
presidencia él abiertamente ya lo ha
dicho quiere ser precandidato
presidencial el partido republicano y
esto lo mete en este manto de dudas
sobre Por qué se llevó esta información
confidencial y que había ahí si la ha
compartido con otras personas que pueda
poner en riesgo la seguridad de Estados
Unidos
y cuáles son las reacciones Perdón
Cristóbal Cuáles son las reacciones
desde Washington sobre este tema
precisamente el ex presidente Donald
Trump que también está siendo
investigado por llevarse documentos
confidenciales a su mansión en su red
social dijo que por favor dejaran
tranquilo a Mike pence a su
vicepresidente que él ha sido inocente y
fue inocente durante todo su
administración de cualquier crimen que
se le acusa que lo dejen tranquilo y
pues varios congresistas ya han salido
también a defender de alguna manera a
Mike pence diciendo que no creen que
haya habido intención mala
tratado el vicepresidente de haberse
llevado documentos o secretos de estado
sin embargo pues lo dice el
vicepresidente que está siendo
investigado y lo que se lo que se espera
es que también el congreso que en este
momento la cámara de representantes es
republicano y ya empezó una
investigación también para Joe biden
Pues precisamente ese congreso sea
cuestionado de por qué no entonces
empezar también una investigación
por haberse llevado o tener estos
documentos confidenciales En todo caso
muchos cuestionamientos acá en
Washington sobre esta Nueva Ola de
líderes llevándose documentos
confidenciales a sus lugares privados